[Music]
hmm
all right well we're welcome back
everyone we're delighted to
be able to have everyone join this
presentation which will really carry us
through a number of the
leading figures in the area of canine
genetics
and genomics but also with the clinical
care
and management of dogs with cancer as
well
i have the privilege of introducing our
first
presenter uh which is dr amy
leblanc from the national cancer
institute her current position as the
director of comparative oncology at the
center
the center for cancer research within
the nci at the national institutes of
health
amy received her degree from michigan
state university both her bachelor's and
her dvm degrees
and then she went on to uh work at
an internship at texas a m university
in animal medicine and surgery did her
residency in oncology
at lsu and then
went on to a faculty position at the
university of
tennessee she's
a board-certified veterinary oncologist
director again of this ccr program
and i can tell you again from experience
that she does a remarkable job
managing and overseeing the operations
of this of
also the comparative oncology tria uh
trials consortium or cotc
which design and executes a number of
clinical trials
uh in support of the work from the nci
with that i'll ask that we
receive our first presentation from dr
leblanc
thank you all for joining us today for
the pause for a cure symposium thank you
to lab roots and to ulrica for all of
her hard work and bringing us
together in a virtual format so i'm
really excited today
to share with you some thoughts on how
genomic data
biomarkers and drug development within
the context of comparative oncology
how that landscapes evolving and um sort
of
give my impression on where we've been
and where we're headed and
reasons to be really excited about the
future
so the state of comparative oncology in
north america is incredibly strong and
growing stronger and stronger um every
year
um there are so many um talented and
and brilliant people working very hard
across
our country and really around the world
to really realize the power that
comparative oncology has
in helping not only our vulnerable
pediatric patients but also
the dogs that share our lives um
and so not just within the nci and our
the program that i direct intramurally
but also within other institutes within
the national
um institutes of health um
people working very hard within the
veterinary and comparative
academic centers around the world
to really integrate our efforts around
studying
new concepts and new drug trials and
new druggable and molecular targets
within dogs that
are naturally developing cancer within
their lifespan
but then also partnering and integrating
this uh discovery and these this new
information
with stakeholders on the pediatric side
so specifically within the children's
oncology group
uh the ctep and next portfolios within
the nci
to again you know pull everybody
together from pharma and other
philanthropic philanthropic
opportunities to support from a funding
standpoint
these trials that we can conduct within
um
the veterinary comparative oncology
trials consortium
and other cooperative consortia that are
developing
around the world to really generate data
from these patients
um these canine patients to really
advance our knowledge and
and um bring everybody forward it's a
really exciting time
i think you would all agree with me in
that in that sense
and and so you know this is um a concept
that
is not new to this group but bears
repeating that
it's an incredibly powerful opportunity
to study cancer
that naturally develops in dogs because
it is a naturally occurring
spontaneous environment tumors co-evolve
with the host
and they generate relevant stromal and
microenvironmental changes as tumors
develop and progress
and within the context of veterinary
care we can apply
chemotherapy surgery radiotherapy and
combination strategies to help combat
tumor progression in dogs and as as we
do that we have opportunities to really
learn
and refine our approach because
dog owners have the flexibility to
choose
a lot of different options that are
offered to them for their pet's care
we have the opportunity again to look at
drugs within the context of treatment
naive disease
and really learn about the impact of
these new
therapies on tumor progression within
the context of routine veterinary care
which is really a unique and exciting
opportunity
um and so i'm just going to highlight a
couple of examples of where we have
done these types of trials over the last
several years
and what we have learned that has been
really exciting
and a huge opportunity to then just
look beyond efficacy but also marry that
that data with tolerability and then the
ability
to explore um pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamic
data but also then look at companion
biomarkers that are
relevant not just for the dogs that are
involved in the clinical trial but also
for eventual use of these new agents and
people so
a really great example was the first
cotc trial that was conducted
um probably almost now 15 years ago
which was
a phase one study of tnf
that was linked to
a phage particle and allowed delivery of
tnf
to tumor vasculature while sparing
normal vasculature
thus really providing a nice targeted
approach to delivery of this
in naturally occurring tumors and we
were actually able to conduct this trial
in dogs
and really generated an exciting amount
of information
that informed the follow-on phase one
trials of this agent and people
and so i enrolled the dog on this trial
when i was an investigator at the
university of tennessee
and so this is the dog that i treated
coco and this is a little girl who
lived in the same family as coco and um
and what was really valuable about the
experience was that not only did we help
coco who responded beautifully to this
agent but she lived an additional four
years and got to share her life with
this little girl who
you know this was her a part of her
family and um so
really exciting i always think about
this this patient because
um what we did and learned from this
agent not only helped
really move this asian forward but
really helped enrich
the entire family around cocoa
it just really helps me stay centered
when we're thinking about
all the challenges we face in drug
development and all the challenges and
complexity of studying
um new drugs and developing new drugs
for cancer
another really exciting opportunity was
an nci sponsored
evaluation of um choke one inhibitors
the indigenous equilibrium
class and what we did in this trial was
look at three different agents and try
to discern the differences between them
but also
develop a better understanding of what
biomarkers
were the best for looking at the drug
response
to really then inform what biomarkers
and what type of samples would be
best collected within the context of a
human trial
and so within this trial we had a lot of
questions to ask and answer
one of course was safety and
tolerability of this class and tumor
bearing dogs with
in this case it was uh lymphoma um but
looking at comparative toxicity profiles
across these three agents to pick a
winner
so to speak and then also marry that
data with
pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
profiles that helped
relate the um the exposure to these
drugs to a response
um and really again ask the question
the question of whether or not these
agents actually have an efficacy signal
in this disease
um and so this work um was incredibly
rich and long-standing and a huge amount
of effort from
lots of people within the veterinary
comparative oncology community
and it led to a really nice publication
of this data
that describes the strengths and the
amazing output of this trial but also
then helped develop
data around a pd assay to look at
exposure um from the drug back to
biomarkers that could then be
related to um to human study of these
of these agents in a phase one setting
so so much information came out of this
work
that again it provides
you know a really exciting opportunity
to highlight the strength of comparative
oncology drug trials and what they can
mean not just for the patients the dog
patients that are enrolled in them
but also for future work with those
agents and in other species like humans
um and then finally in the um as far as
previous examples
i'll highlight cotc 10 which was a
safety and biological activity study of
immunocytokines and melanoma first
as a specific example so this agent
was really sort of back when this trial
was happening in like 2007
2008 2009 it was really unclear back
then whether or not this agent actually
was worth
um further study and through working
dogs with a variety of solid tumors but
then also specifically in melanoma we
were
able to identify again a really strong
relationship between drug exposure
pk and pharmacodynamic responses
but then also highlight an efficacy
signal in dogs with measurable melanoma
and so i think without that data my
understanding was that this agent
may have been at that point abandoned
and it was when the
the dog data was received by the sponsor
that a renewed interest in advancing
this agent forward occurred
enough to allow the nci to support the
ind for its study in uh
in a phase one setting um and then
relate those findings then back to what
we had learned in dogs and
um and so reprioritization of that agent
occurred
of the nhs il-12 construct after the
data was received from dogs in 2010
and if you if you read further into the
phase one results in people
you can see that the canine data was
very comparable to human data
a very similar ae profile
comparable pd readout and a very similar
maximum tolerated dose so
really exciting opportunity to highlight
across these three examples of where
dogs have really informed and really set
the scene for
um advancement of agents in um in a
variety of settings and
into human use and i think that's
probably where
um you know just to summarize where we
have been you know i think all of us
agree
that naturally occurring dogs that
naturally occurring cancers that develop
in pet dogs are a great model system for
certain human cancers
it's not going to be a perfect fit
across all these different tumors that
dogs develop
but that if we put a focus on
data-driven research we can
bridge human and canine oncology in a
really meaningful way
and ultimately i think what we all like
to see is that that comparative approach
can
impact human health certainly we
we care about these canine patients and
we we in this
setting today of the symposium we're
very focused on pediatric
outcomes but i think that's really
should be our goal
is my goal that we learn and study and
and support dogs through their
their journey of developing cancer and
we want to help them as patients and
members of our family
but we also want to have that work
positively impact human health outcomes
so you know there have been a
significant amount of efforts made in
the last
five to eight years to really fill these
gaps in what we know about canine cancer
and how it can be related to improving
our knowledge for people um so the nih
funding for comparative
comparative oncology initiatives has
really taken off
um especially the last few years and you
will hear
more about the outcome of these nci
funding opportunities within
this meeting and others i'll also just
quickly nod to some comparative
pathology boards that we have conducted
within my program and within within mark
simpson's group within the nci
looking at comparative pathologic
features of melanoma and glioma and
meningioma
again with the goal to really relate
dogs to people and ask
where are they similar where are they
different and how can physicians and
veterinarians
involved in cancer care learn from each
other
we've also been very fortunate to have
morris animal foundation
and the quad w foundation sponsor trials
and osteosarcoma that have been
conducted through the cotc
infrastructure osteosarcoma being a
really critically important pediatric
tumor that we will discuss a lot during
this meeting
another really exciting opportunity lies
i think in cell-based therapies so you
will also hear about
folks working within car t and case
based cell therapies so again that's a
really exciting new opportunity for us
to learn
and there have been just an amazing
amount of new efforts in
developing new clinical trial consortia
and philanthropic
opportunities to fund these these
studies and dogs
as well as um data sharing and
harmonization efforts so
it's a really exciting time for us and i
think we have a lot to look forward to
in the future
so you know in thinking about what are
the questions that we probably should be
thinking now to further establish
relevance
to of dogs to pediatric patients i think
you know one of the obvious questions is
you know we've spent a lot of time and
you'll hear more about how osteosarcoma
work and dogs has informed pediatric
osteosarcoma care
but what other canine tumors might have
shared molecular features
and what other data sets and
biospecimens are really needed to
explore those relationships and then
really
once we learn and gather more data how
best to harmonize
analytical platforms and enhance ability
and opportunities to share that data
with others in the community
and then how again in the
immunotherapeutics
realm how can dogs best informed new
immunotherapeutic strategies for
pediatric patients
um we will be specifically in my program
working
more deeply in osteosarcoma to help
answer
some questions about genomic
characterization
we plan to really define patient
subgroups for specific
therapeutic testing and to really help
define prognostic signatures that relate
dog and human osteosarcoma
with an eye towards again just working
with our human um
counterparts to identify new druggable
targets
um and that lies within the dog squared
project which is
a new initiative within my program here
at the nci to build out
and build upon the comparative molecular
profiling that we are
more and more getting a better
understanding for um
we really are excited about starting to
look at both
dogs that unfortunately succumb very
early during their chemotherapy and
surgery approach to
the disease to those that have more of
an elite
long-term response to therapy and try to
understand the differences between those
populations
and then share this data with the
community through the nci's integrated
canine data commons
to really say this is what we've learned
let's see what other people's ideas are
and enable a cloud-based analytical
tools to help interrogate this
genomic data um to the benefit
for for all of our patients
so what lies ahead for us i mean i think
a lot actually
is available for us to be excited about
and really
set the scene for what we all want to
move
forward towards i think our challenges
are
to continue to emphasize the scientific
dialogue
about the applicability and validity of
the dog model
dog patients as models for pediatric
patients
really requires a lot of careful thought
about where
the similarities but maybe more
importantly the differences lie
to strategically advanced new
therapeutic concepts
we all continue to strive to maintain
really high standards for clinical trial
conduct execution and reporting and
design of those trials so that's a
really important
challenge for us and i'm really excited
to harmonize our efforts with the
children's oncology group to make sure
that what we do
specifically within the context of
osteosarcoma is really informative and
relevant for our pediatric counterparts
and then to continue working very hard
to develop a portfolio of canine
specific reagents and
correlative assays because that is a
huge challenge for us working within
dogs
there aren't um a huge library of
analytical tools and reagents that are
canine specific
and so as that part continues to develop
i think that will really help our
efforts
um and enhance the ability to see canine
data
inform human work so i'll end there and
really say
i'm excited to be here i think there's a
lot of opportunity we have an incredible
lineup of speakers that you've
already heard from or will hear from
within today and tomorrow and so
um a huge thank you to my group at the
nci and others within the nih and
outside of the nih that have really
enhanced my experience
um in comparative oncology and i'm
excited to partner with you all to move
forward on
on all of these and um additional
concepts that we will develop
maybe during this meeting and and beyond
for sure so
thanks for your attention i'm happy to
take any questions uh during the break
okay thank you very much uh we really
appreciate
dr leblanc the presentation the overview
of how the nci
through the cotc is without question
brought
the comparative oncology community
together across a series of the clinical
trials
and as you began to highlight we'll hear
more we know about the
integrated canine data commons or icdc
over the course of this presentation and
over the course of the day
we are going to be holding questions uh
until the
end of the session that we have which is
coming up now
entitled the canine genetics and
biomarker data in the context of human
uh key data sets you'll be hearing from
five different presenters
one of those includes uh dr leblanc
you've just heard from and in that first
presentation that uh you'll hear from in
in just a moment uh you'll also hear
from
dr heather gardner i'll just briefly
introduce
heather her background was training in
dvm in washington state then went to the
ohio state university
where she completed her residency in
medical oncology
she's now at tufts university
and is a new assistant research
professor in the coming school of
veterinary medicine at tufts
so with with that we will introduce the
the first presentation
that from both dr leblanc
and
and dr gardner as well so please begin
the presentation
so we're going to go ahead and start out
today's session on the comparative
canine osteosarcoma genetics discussion
so i'm joined today by heather gardner
who's a research assistant professor
at the cummings school of veterinary
medicine my name is amy leblanc i'm the
director of the
national cancer institute's comparative
oncology program
and we're thrilled to be here to share
our vision and some data that we have
respectively between our two groups and
to talk about
the future of this particularly exciting
aspect of comparative oncology also a
huge thank you to el rica
and the organizers and the folks from
lab roots to help make this possible
today
so i'm going to let heather go ahead and
get us started today with
an overview of the
genomics data that she has generated
from her lab and then
i'll come back and talk about some of
the things that we're working on at the
nci
to carry it forward so heather
thanks so much um so uh before we get
into
uh the genetics data just to make sure
we're all on the same page as
many of you are aware osteosarcoma is
the most common primary bone tumor that
we recognize in dogs
with over 25 000 cases being diagnosed
annually
we also recognize many clinical and
molecular features
of this disease that are shared between
species and
these have supported the use of canine
osteosarcoma as a model for the human
condition
and this includes a similar clinical
presentation
response to platinum-based therapy and
development of
drug-resistant metastatic disease we
also see similar
clinical excuse me molecular and genetic
aberrations in both
canine and human osteosarcoma but to
effectively utilize the spontaneous
disease in dogs and help us
understand the disease across species
it's really important to understand the
similarities and
differences that occur between them
and so if we look at some of the
recognized genetic features in
osteosarcoma
we see that both the type and incidence
of changes
are fairly well conserved between both
species and so the table here is is
really just showing some of the common
tumor suppressor genes
and oncogenes that we recognize in
osteosarcoma and we see
again similar incidents and type of
changes including copy number games in
mid
um and copy number losses in dlg2 across
both species
um and so i'm thinking about some of
these these recognized features and how
we
how we utilize them um
if we if we take a step back and think
about what this means very simply put
we're really using the molecular and
genetic features of the disease
to help inform clinical application um
and when we look at this we do recognize
several opportunities to fill gaps in
our understanding of osteosarcoma and
some of those are highlighted here
these range from characterization of the
genomic landscape of both primary and
metastatic disease which is
critical as patients are succumbing to
metastatic disease
but most of our understanding of the
genetics of osteosarcoma is really
related to the primary tumor
and then using that information to
understand the function of genetic
operations ideally in prospective
settings
um additionally many of the
computational tools that we use to
analyze canine data
were developed to analyze human samples
and these were done
using established platforms with best
practice guidelines and data sets that
help
optimize those tools and because similar
guidance isn't as widely available
for canine samples this can introduce
bias and create
challenges related to comparing outputs
across data sets
and so for the rest of the time i'd like
to highlight a few of the efforts that
have been undertaken to address these
challenges
and one of these was supported by the
nci
um where administrative supplements for
p30
cancer center support grants were
were performed and these were designed
to support research
and canine tumors through collaboration
of nci designated cancer centers and
veterinary medical colleges the
supplements actually supported
evaluation
across six canine tumor types with
comparative relevance including
osteosarcoma
and one of the data sets that came out
of this effort was
a whole genome sequencing of 24 primary
canine osteosarcoma tumor samples
and this dataset helped to support many
of the features that we recognize
in both canine and in human osteosarcoma
i'm including a structurally complex
landscape with high incidence of
structural variants and copy number
changes um including chromosomal
translocations
as well as aberrations in signaling
pathways that are known to be important
in human osteosarcoma
including the map kinase and pi3 kinase
signal pathways
this data data was also interesting in
that it provided some insight
into unique features of canine
osteosarcoma
including a high incidence of
alterations in chromatin regulatory
genes
in particular set d2 where both point
mutations and structural variants were
identified
in 42 percent of samples as well as
deletions and copy number losses in dmd
the
gene that encodes dystrophin
and so together these data help to
provide a blueprint
for validating these findings across a
larger number of both primary and
metastatic tumor samples
and then also characterizing the
functional significance
of some of these unique features of the
canine disease
and with that i'll let amy
kind of follow up with um with
some of the data that she has generated
great thank you heather um and so i
can't underscore enough how important
uh the data that heather's group has
generated because it really helped us
again
know where to go next and turn forward
our work um that's carried out within
the context of
uh canine tumor viable that's collected
through clinical trial efforts
so one of the components of the nci's
comparative oncology
program is a trials consortium which
unites drug development
and other uh research consortium
stakeholders through a network of
clinical trials
sites that exist at veterinary that are
veterinary medical colleges and
schools across the u.s and canada and so
when we
are able to connect these stakeholders
through
tech transfer and the respective
clinical oncology teams at these
veterinary schools it becomes a really
powerful mechanism for conducting
multi-center clinical trials and one of
the things that
we've done a lot lately are through the
support of the morris animal foundation
and also the quad w foundation
we've conducted a series of clinical
trials and osteosarcoma
and although the results of these trials
are still ongoing in some respects
this really striking feature here is
that over the last several years we've
been able to
enroll over 400 dogs with osteosarcoma
and really conduct a very prescriptive
controlled way
the collection of a really nice series
of
biological samples collected from these
patients that really
um is pretty powerful because all of
these tumors and all of these patients
have now a strong demographic data and
clinical outcome data attached to them
so they become really valuable
um not just in the setting of the
clinical trial and drug development but
also for future biologic questions
so right now we have data that is coming
out from agile rapamycin which
um has shown in this trial within
appendicular
um osteosarcoma in dogs when added to a
standard of care backbone it does not
extend the disease-free interval or
survival
however though the value here lies in
the fact that again we have clinically
um annotated samples with really strong
detailed outcome data that help us then
go back
and define uh what our next steps could
be and
identifying druggable targets and things
that have translational relevance
between the dog and the human
so what we're doing at the nci is
launching the dog squared project
um and that stands for either you know
however you want to choose deciphering
or decoding the osteosarcoma genome and
dogs
and there's three main components to
this project
i'm going to touch on the first one
which again leverages
these these outcome-linked clinical
biospecimen samples
that allow us to conduct studies in bulk
genomics
to start with that help i think our
first challenge would be to identify
and relate subtypes and prognostic
signatures to to humans
we have other plans that are relating to
tumor heterogeneity studies and also
some single cell sequencing
that really again to heather's point
help us gather more information outside
of just
primary tumors and really help explore
biology that relates to metastatic
progression
in the microenvironment around these
tumors
so our goals and methods just broadly
stated here are to create
a comprehensive data set that describes
that molecular landscape again building
off the excellent work of heather and
others in this field
we leverage that outcome linked
biospecimen repository by
studying both primary tumors but also a
collection of matched
metastases from those primary tumors we
also have
biofluids pbmcs serum and plasma
and we aim to integrate that data with
not only
existing k9 data sets but also with
human osteosarcoma data sets that have
been generated
through for example the nci target
initiative here within the intramural
program
and we're hoping that again because we
have the outcome data we can then begin
to define
prognostic signatures that may relate to
patients who
perhaps may fail chemotherapy very early
on but then also
understand why then a group of dogs
seems to be an incredibly long-lived or
elite responder group
and then try to understand how those
signatures may relate back
to their human counterparts
and we have through our collaboration
with folks at the
national center for advancing
translational sciences the ncats
division of nih
we have helped to build with their help
um and a combined experimental and
bioinformatics pipeline that
relates these genomic findings um to
druggable disease and
the um more improved understanding
of how these changes relate again back
to humans
um and so we've already begun to really
look at some of this data from the
standpoint
of um uh not only what it shows us
and the relation to again some of the
things that heather has pointed out like
mick amplification
um and p53 loss which we know are
sort of hallmark changes not only in
existing dog data but are
also very important changes that are
already seen in humans too
um we know that you know based on these
um these data that we
are seeing a lot of very strong
similarities between our samples
and data derived from samples from other
groups so
this works ongoing and we hope to be
able to share more information about the
similarities and differences that
we identified from the copy number
and transcriptomic data sets but also
getting to more
fine mapping and deep sequencing of
these samples and dogs
and so what we envision here is that it
becomes
sort of this self-propelling mechanism
where
we start again at the top with defining
the genomic landscape
we integrate those data sets from dogs
and with existing human and other canine
datasets
we then use that information to identify
new druggable targets for future studies
we can then take those targets back to
the lab and share them with others that
work in the space
to more deeply interrogate mechanism
within
existing and maybe potentially generate
new preclinical mouse models
and then collectively we then use that
information to prioritize
the next generation of therapeutic
approaches that we can then roll out
through our clinical trial network
throughout the program here at the nci
so then it becomes this really
self-evolving mechanism that builds and
builds constantly on itself
leveraging existing tools and expertise
to help outcomes for both dogs and
and for humans so i think
in closing i think you know heather and
i are both really committed to
continuing to interrogate and
comparatively assess this landscape
i think heather and i both agree and
i'll
certainly allow heather to chime in here
of course
that it's really important to keep
exploring educal facets
with disease to highlight these
opportunities we have a lot of work to
do still
to look at the global immune environment
in which the disease
progresses and um and responds to
therapy with
respect to the immune environment and
also a lot of
ongoing questions about local
microenvironment changes within
the bone primary tumor and also within
metastatic sites
and again a really exciting opportunity
to identify good
new druggable molecular pathways that
are relevant to both species
and to look at prognostic signatures as
well
so i'll acknowledge my team from the nci
and others
and i'll turn it back over to heather to
finish it up
thanks amy um yeah again i just need to
reiterate
everything that mentioned you know
there's
i think there's a lot of opportunities
um that are
that are coming up as we're generating
more and more data and learning
more about the the similarities and
differences about
the genetic landscape of this disease um
and again just briefly acknowledging the
team that was involved in the
work that i presented as well too was
definitely a collaborative effort
um with with a lot of people that were
involved
and we're happy to take any questions
thank you yes thank you so much
well thank you really both dr leblanc
and dr gardner for
your presentation and uh let me
remind all of those listening that we do
hope that there'll be the submission
of questions that can be answered by all
of the presenters at the
during the discussion session coming up
well as we move forward the next speaker
is dr will hendricks
will received his bachelor's degree from
arizona state university and molecular
biosciences went on to get his
both his phd and his post doctoral
fellowship at johns hopkins university
in cell molecular medicine and the
laboratory of bert vogelstein and ken
kinsler argue you arguably the
most significant genomics lab in the
country
where he actually worked on some viral
delivery aspects that involved the
canine as well
but moving then to tjen
he's currently an assistant professor
and
basically the program lead for our
program and canine health and
performance
that focuses on cancer so with that i
will
ask if we could please start the video
hi everyone i'm will hendricks
an assistant professor of integrated
cancer genomics at tgen
first i want to thank all rika and the
meeting organizers for putting on this
incredible meeting
and particularly this year for so nimbly
shifting the format to a virtual meeting
last year's meeting and this year's
meeting already have proven critically
important
not just for bringing together
stakeholders but also for really shining
a light on
individual patients who motivate the
work that we do
my focus today will be on providing you
all with a crash course
on what we're learning of canine cancer
genome landscapes
and genomic biomarkers and what i hope
will be a view complementary to other
presentations you'll be watching today
that will be more deeply mining a number
of these topics and tumor types
here are my disclosures i won't be
discussing video morris products today
perhaps no one in this audience would
debate this but let's start from first
principles by acknowledging that canine
cancer is a genetic disease
that arises through stepwise
accumulation of mutations and genes that
regulate cell life
and death even though we don't yet have
data that comprehensively maps this
process
across different stages of tumor
progression in the same patient
we do have studies that support the
genomic complexity
and burden of driver mutations increases
with increasing grade
one example is from mast cell tumors and
work done by dr breen
showing increasing levels of copy number
variation with increasing mast cell
tumor grade
represented here by the overall copy
number penetrance plots at the top
as well as the individual box plots
showing total c and v
number on the left and c and v length on
the right
with significant correlations with low
and high grade mast cell tumors
other studies like those looking at
primary versus mets
and other contexts like melanocytoma
versus malignant melanoma also support
that this process occurs
a number of advances over the years in
canine genome mapping
shown in gray on this timeline as well
as canine cancer genetics shown in white
over the past 30 years these have been
critical for understanding
canine cancer's genetic basis
here i plotted some of those events in a
pre-next-gen sequencing timeline leading
up to 2014
when canine cancer genomic studies using
ngs started to emerge at a more steady
pace
in human cancer genomics individual labs
alongside national
and international consortia and
commercial sequencing efforts
have all jointly resulted in sequencing
of hundreds of thousands of human cancer
genomes
and yet we still recognize that in human
cancer genomics there's work to be done
we still need to better understand
cancer genome variation during the
course of disease and treatment
we need to understand infra-tumoral
genomic heterogeneity and evolution
we need to understand variation in
cancer genomes across populations and
emits health disparities
and beyond
these data though and the teams that
have generated them provide
guideposts and models that help us
navigate what i see is a growing
and oncoming flood of canine cancer
genomic data
that's begun to reshape how we're
understanding
cancer in pet dogs and it's going to
accelerate our ability to make
connections between dogs and humans
a growing number of federal and local
efforts some of which are listed here
in the u.s and abroad are driving a
positive trend line in the publication
of canine cancer genomes
even if it's linear today and not yet
logarithmic
based on structured pubmed searches for
canine cancer genomics public
publications that use ngs whether pano
panels exomes genomes etc here's a
recent survey of the data we have in
publication today
more than 300 published canine cancer
genomes
ordered here by the most common tumor
types in dogs from lymphoma to mast cell
tumor on down
many of these instances are more
populated than others in part due to
their comparative
value such as in lymphoma and
osteosarcoma
for example and for our purposes today
i'll focus on a brief overview of three
tumor types most relevant to comparative
studies of canine and pediatric cancers
although there's certainly value in
looking at many of these canine tumor
types from a genetic basket perspective
i also want us to reflect not only on
what we know of canine cancer genomes
and driver mutations in isolation
but also to think about actionability
horizons based on those mutations
this orients us to understanding where
mutations sit in relation to research
hypotheses
and a clinical utility is diagnostic
prognostic or predictive biomarkers
this helps to keep us focused on the
patient impact of what we're doing
whether canine or human patients
from the studies surveyed in the
previous slide as well as hundreds of
additional pubs using non-ngs technology
to describe genetic alterations in
clinical associations and pet dogs
i'd argue that there are more than 100
cancer genes that have been
linked to canine cancer
and that more than 1 000 individual
mutations have shown some association
with canine cancer diagnosis
prognosis treatment response or tumor
biology
that these numbers are relatively close
to their human counterparts reflects the
high yield of the genetic and genomic
work done to date
but we still clearly have a ways to go
as reflected in the bottom row of
numbers
arguably we have only one predictive
biomarker that's recognized by consensus
work
in canine that's the association of kit
mutations with
tecerinib or bacitinib response and mast
cell tumors
but even there the consensus is more
that more data is needed
rather than a clear association we're
also short on companion diagnostics
recognized by consensus and we're short
on biomarker-driven clinical trials
but i'd also argue that these aspects
are poised for change being driven by
the flow of genomic data
i think it's worth noting that clinical
trials particularly
incorporating genetic biomarkers are
going to be increasingly powerful due to
the difficulty of running large
randomized clinical trials and pet dogs
which one needs in order to identify
small to moderate effect sizes
i'm now going to briefly review what
we're learning about the genomic
underpinnings of three tumor types with
particular relevance to pediatric
oncology
lymphoma osteosarcoma and glioma others
in this meeting have or will be driving
diving more deeply into some of this
work first for lymphoma
in this landscape i've leaned on a
number of seminal studies that include
cytogenetic targeted sequencing and ngs
studies to create a merged view of the
lymphoma genomic landscape
i plotted b-cell lymphoma mutations in
the front rust-colored plot
and t-cell lymphoma mutations in the
lightest lighter sand-colored plot in
the back
they move by frequency and b-cell
lymphoma from left to right and then by
frequency and t-cell from right to left
so you can visualize some of the overlap
a big caveat here is that lymphoma is
fairly heterogeneous in its cell of
origin
particularly for t cell lymphoma so this
is certainly a pan lymphoma
generalization but hopefully helpful
nonetheless
for picking out important genes and
features for example we know that mick
gains or in rare cases
activating point mutations are common
events in both
b and t cell lymphoma whereas conversely
we've recently learned that trap three
inactivating mutations
are common in dlbcl but don't occur in
other lymphoma types
overall this work particularly recent
ngs work
has highlighted the low mutation burden
of canine lymphoma
it's highlighted signs of breed specific
mutation patterns
and subtype specific driver mutations
that we're understanding with increasing
resolution
for the summary of the osteosarcoma
landscape i've leaned on two recent ngs
studies
as well as dr leblanc's recent review to
generate a view of canine osteosarcoma
in the front
and human osteosarcoma in the back here
we can see the convergence
of frequent p53 mutation is a defining
feature in both cancers
with potential divergence in other areas
like set d2
and dmd losses and canine that we don't
see in human or more frequent rb1 loss
in human
than is seen in canine as with lymphoma
canine osteosarcoma bears a low tmb
but like human osteo it's very
structurally complex with abundant
translocations
small studies have also suggested that
metastases have higher tmb
and may acquire new drivers a feature
that's ripe for follow-up
work and holds particular relevance for
how we think about treatment
genomic profiling in general and
cross-species studies
canine glioma has also been
comprehensively profiled in this case by
dr verhack and his team
in work that has highlighted its
similarity to human pediatric glioma
answering important questions about
whether tumors in old dogs
might still look like tumors in young
humans
in this large multi-omic study they
found low tmb and methylation patterns
more closely resembling pediatric than
adult human nucleoma
and it as has been a recurrent theme
across these studies
they also identified driver mutations
shared with human glioma such as pdgfra
pic3ca
and idh mutations they also identified
significant aneulity in the study
finally i'll leave our survey exercise
with a view
across genomic data from most of the
tumor type sequence to date
that are in publication this is recent
work from dr shaying zhao
at georgia in which her team uniformly q
seed and reprocessed
publicly deposited genomic sequences
to identify pan cancer features and
published this data as a preprint in
bioarchive
you can see the oncoprint of driver
mutations across cancer types
you can see that p53 is one of the most
commonly mutated genes in these cancer
types
and importantly you can also see a
significant correlation between
the presence of p53 mutations and tumor
mutation burden
similarly to what had been observed in
osteosarcoma but here in a pan cancer
setting
i'd like to finish by viewing these data
through the lens of their utility as
biomarkers
both to guide clinical care of pet dogs
with cancer but also to guide ongoing
comparative research in dogs
and in humans i'm going to cast a
conceptual framework here for how we can
view canine cancer genomic biomarkers by
leveraging
evidence-based consensus guidelines from
human clinical genomics
these guidelines break variants down
into four tiers and those four
shaded overall boxes
they're based on evidence supporting
their association with clinical
phenotype
from on the left strong clinical
significance
to potential clinical significance to
unknown significance to confirm benign
across those four boxes within tier one
strong clinical significance and to
potential clinical significance
we also have sub-levels that depend on
the evidence types and strength
from fda approved therapies including
professional guidelines for tier 1 level
a
to pre-clinical trials or case reports
without consensus for tier 2 d
for the sake of simplicity for our
exercise
though let's view these as level one
variants being those with any biomarker
association from tier one or tier two
and level two being variants of unknown
clinical significance
and then benign as a separate category
so to wrap up a brief and generalized
version of this exercise let's look back
at the lymphoma osteoglioma landscapes
that we previously summarized through
the lens of what could constitute a
level one biomarker solely based on
canine data
plotted here for lymphoma
um osteoglioma
for uh lymphoma i've plotted on the
bottom of
of the um uh chart
a gray square if the mutation is
relevant to b and t cell it's rust
colored if it's relevant
only to b cell and it's sand colored if
it's only t
cell you can see that the diagnostic
class
level 1 dx is most abundant
since by definition these are
essentially the disease characteristic
mutations
level one px prognostic and tx
therapeutic or predictive
associations are of course more limited
and if we had more time we could also
sub-categorize these to account for what
evidence has been published in the same
tumor type
versus evidence in different tumor types
and what types of evidence
for example clinical data is limited for
all of these
in dog but preclinical data is more
abundant
an example of where this is relevant is
that p53 bears one of only two drug
relevant associations across these tumor
types
but these data are from pre-clinical
drug screens and so according to the
prior guidelines they'd be tier 2d
they're nonetheless a valuable jumping
off point the annotation done here is
from primary canine literature but if we
were to also
infer from human biomarker data and pan
cancer data at that
these horizons would expand dramatically
even though there are important caveats
around those kinds of inference
further linkages of many of these driver
alterations to human clinical
investigation
studies are even more abundant from mick
to pic3ca to cdk4 for example
and ultimately we also have a wealth of
level 2 mutations that the work of many
folks in this meeting
will continue to link to clinical
phenotypes
so to sum up what are some of the key
observations
that we see from canine cancer genome
sequencing studies
we see mutation patterns resembling
those in human cancer
we see conserved but also unique cancer
drivers
we see a low tumor mutation burden where
high burden is present it's rare and
associated with p53
we also see genomic biomarkers are
increasingly abundant
what are the key needs
fortunately what you've already heard
and will be hearing over the course of
today and tomorrow
will speak into many of these needs and
you'll clearly see that we as a
community are making strong headway
not just in our efforts to improve
cancer care across species but also
in our efforts to help pet dogs and
these really come down to needing
more tools more data better
harmonization
more drugs and consensus guidelines
thank you
well we appreciate the fact that both
doctors
leblanc and gardner as well as dr
hendricks have helped paint a picture of
not just what we know but areas that
particularly are not
studied in the depth that we would have
idea ideally uh
wished and our next presenter is dr role
verhock who is one of the leaders in
really diving deeply
into canine cancer dr verhack
received his phd in masters and the
netherlands went on to matt meyerson's
lab at the broad institute
then spent time as a visiting scientist
with john
quackenbush before he went to the md
anderson
cancer center in houston where he rose
through the ranks from
assistant and associate professor before
moving to the jackson labs
where he leads aspects associated with
all of their computational biology
and thankfully for us also in the uh
area of uh being able to really focus on
the canine
let me just before we roll this just
remind people please feel free to
begin to put questions in place for any
of these presentations
and now we'll hear from dr verhack
hello my name is rolf verhack i'm a
professor at the jackson laboratory for
genomic medicine
in farmers in connecticut my lab studies
gliomas which are malignant brain tumors
that occur in
adults and in children these tumors are
hard to treat because of their very
infiltrative nature
into the brain which makes it extremely
difficult to resect
distract and resect tumor cells or treat
them with
chemotherapy or radiation therapy
glioma and adults can be grouped
according to idh mutation and 1p92
co-deletion status this means that we
typically recognize
three different types of gliomas in
adults
ones that are characterized by presence
of mutations in idh
as well as in 1p92 coalition this is a
group of tumors that were
traditionally referred to as
oligodendrogliomas
there's also tumors that carry an idh
mutation in absence of the 1p9tq
correlation
and these are predominantly known as
astrocytomas
finally adult gliomites where no
mutations in idh are found
are typically glioblastomas this last
group
is most notorious for their particularly
poor prognosis
the cancer genome atlas in which i
played some role reported this
this grouping in 2015 and in 2016 it has
been
included in the classification
put out by the world health organization
of central nervous system tumors
these three categories of glioma are not
just clinically meaningful
as they strongly predict prognosis and
as such
play a major role in determining the
optimal treatment plan for these
patients
but they're also indicating three
biologically very different entities
as you can tell from this figure leomas
marked by the presence of 1p92 code
deletions
also nearly always contain mutations in
the terpromotor
as well as frequent alterations of genes
like cic and fubp1
idh mutated but non-co-diluted gliomas
are almost never mutated in the third
promoter but almost always
carry p53 and atrx mutations
and then finally the idh wild-type group
the glucose
lac idh mutations
are marked by egfr and cdtn2a mutations
and alterations
and again frequently inter-promoter
mutations are seen
a question that my lab is interested in
is that the mutation profiles that we
detect
when the when we study clear must from
patients
are the mutation profiles as the patient
has developed symptoms
at that point in time these tumors have
been growing for some period
and we've been interested to learn to
study the phases and the
the the behavior of the tumor cells from
initiation
all the way up until cancer diagnosis
we're also interested
in studying what happens after cancer
diagnosis
and we do that as part of the glioma
longitudinal analysis or glass
consortium
but i won't be discussing that work
today
in this theoretical exercise that we
published in 2018
we hypothesized that the molecular life
history of gliamas up until diagnosis
can be summarized into five different
phases of glymogenesis
there's a period of initial growth a
period of oncogene-induced senescence
followed by stress growth replicative
senescence
and finally immortalized growth
this has two implications first we
believe that each of these
each of these phases is marked by the
acquisition of particular
alterations in particular genes in
particular continents
for example glioma initiation we believe
is caused by
mutations in genes like idh which is so
very frequently present in adult tumors
in kids in for example a gene like h3
f3a
or b rath as well as employee
alterations
like whole chromosome 7 gain and
chromosomes and mass
the second implication of this five
phase model
is that in order for a
[Music]
budding tumor cell to become a
full-blown tumor cell
there's a number of barriers that need
to be overcome so a tumor cell
may have a mutation in idh but until it
also acquires a senescence bypass
mutation
like a p16 deletion the tumor cell won't
get out of that phase and will simply
sense and you will not
and a tumor will not fully develop
um in addition to the senescence bypass
implicated by p53 mutations or p16
deletions for example
there is a phase of genomic instability
so unless the tumor cell
enters that phase of genomic instability
it will never become a full-blown
nucleoma
genomic instability is recognized in
gliomas by polyploidization
chromothrypsis the acquisition of double
binders for extra chromosomal dna
and so forth and then finally unless the
tumor cells acquire a mechanism for
maintaining a telomeres
to enter a phase of immortalization
again it will just simply
senesce and die
in gliomas the immortalization phase is
marked by terp promoter mutations
and atrx alterations
the implication of the model and this is
replicated in many other tumor types
is that early glioma cells likely
develop with some frequency
but only in those few unlucky people
where all phases are successfully
completed
pluto's glioma cells gave rise to full
glow gliomas
some additional evidence for this model
is found
in this publication from 2018 by john
hallease group from the kaist institute
of korea
who reported the presence of leoma
associated mutations in non-glioma cells
in the brain cells of a number of ie's
multi-glioblastoma patients
suggesting that these mutations were
actually relatively widespread within
the brain
even though only in some cells that
became glioblastoma cell
of course another way of studying the
natural life history of these tumors
is through comparative oncology which is
the focus of the current medium
with the game and we've become
interested in the approach
some time ago and have studied a large
cohort of canine gliomas
and compare them to pediatric gliomas
which we've
had separated into two subtypes namely
h3 mutant and h3 wild-type
pediatric neurons as well as the three
adult subtypes that i've just talked
about
we reported our results in the ones that
i'm talking about today
and a cancer cell publication that was
published earlier this year with samir
amin
as the first author
so in studying gliomas and companion
dogs the additional reasons are that's
when these are spontaneous tumors in an
immunocompetent environment
and understanding their molecular
characteristics better may help us
develop clinical trials in dogs that can
teach you something about behavioral
humiliating humans
to do so we struck up a collaboration
with dr amy heinberger at md anderson
as well as john levine and beth boudreau
at the
college of veterinary medicine at texas
a m
dogs have a comparable genome to humans
there's comparable histology types so in
glioma and darks
are separated into oligodendrogliomas
and astrocytes elements
and finally there's a breed specific
elevated risk with brachiocephalic dogs
having a greater risk of
developing a glioma and their relatively
longer lifespan
lower the threshold for for example
detecting evolutionary constrained
driver genes
we uh obtained tumor samples with of
course
um uh led by john levine and beth gruder
from postmortem a majority untreated
tumors
in majority these dogs were under
underwent compassionate euthanization
none of the dogs in our study were
all dogs were companion animals none of
them were kept
particularly for the means of our style
we performed whole genome and exome
sequencing on all our samples we in
total acquired 147 samples among which
81 tumors and 65 measure normal tissue
we performed rna-seq and methylation via
reduced
representation by sulfide sequencing on
40 tumor samples basically the samples
with the best quality
and we acquired clinical characteristics
such as age
diagnosis and survival of any of if
any medium we also separated the cohort
into astrocytomas and oligodendromas
where where that very deemed that usual
as a start we compare mutation rates
between canine pediatric and adult
liomas
mutation rates in cancer have been have
been found to be relatively
representative of the age of the patient
so in this figure you can see pediatric
tumors
from humans which we obtained from
public data sets on the left
and mutation rates of adult brain tumors
on the right
and as you can see canine gliomas sit
sort of in the middle
in between those two groups uh
relatively reflective of also the eight
um a diagnosis of the canine patient
we looked at frequently altered genes of
canine glioma genes that had the most
not just the most
they were not the most frequently
mutated but where this also had a
significant implication
via statistical model that we that is
often used in studies of
urine cancer genomics and found that
mutations in
pdgf array and pic3ca which are also
known to occur in both pediatric and
adult human gliama glioma
were also frequent in canine glioma we
did not
observe any third promoter mutations
which is somewhat market because these
are so very frequent in
human adults
we summarized all the alterations both
mutations but also deletions and
amplifications
into pathways and then we
did the same for the data sets we
acquired on pediatric and adulthood
to show that there's three pathways that
are altered in at least 50
of amongst all these three uh glioma
types
which are proliferative signaling in
genome instability
and finally angiogenesis
on the other hand avoiding immune
destruction
is relatively uh is altered with
relatively low frequency
suggesting that gliomas in general do
not need to avoid immune destruction
a result that links directly to the
relatively uh unimpressive
results that have been reported from
clinical trials using immunotherapies
for a new and glioma patients
so in this we can borrow some evidence
for the five-phase
genesis model uh we have defined
tumor initiating events as well as
senescence bypass events
for canines it's unsure what the tumor
initiating events are at this point we
were
we based on the current data set we
don't um think we can make reasonable
assumptions on what those might be
but we see the same genomic instability
as well as evidence for replicative
senescence bypass
and canine gliomas as have been reported
for human gliomas
like pediatric gliomas we do not see
evidence for immortality
associated mutations on the basis of
these results as well as on the basis of
the
mutation rate we concluded that canine
glioma is mostly a model can be used as
a model for human pediatric genome
and less so for adult glioma it lacks a
few critical features of adult clioma
such as the chirp promoter mutations the
[Music]
lower mutation rate and the relatively
high
aneuploidy rates that is observed in
pediatric glioma is replicated in
canines
finally we also found that when we used
the
methylation profiles from the canine
tumors
and classified them according to human
methylation signatures these were a
majority classified as human pediatric
gliomas
confirming our observations from the
genomic data
like human disease we did the canine
glioma micro environment is dominated by
myeloid cells
amy heinberger and her group performed
these immunohistochemistry staining
experiments
of on slides of all three types to show
that
there's a relatively high frequency of
microglia and m2 microfiber
cells and a relatively low number of
t-cells and b-cells
so to conclude canon gliomas are more
similar to pediatric human clioma than
to human adult genome and this is on the
basis of mutation rates
dna methylation classification and high
levels of any boiling
pathways that are important for
hemoglobin are also relevant in canine
glioma
we see this in cell cycle and
proliferation anti-apoptosis as the
genome genome instability and finally
immune suppression is observed across
glioma subtypes
across glioma types which confirms the
role of the brain as an immune
privileged environment
so what is next for our comparative
oncology efforts
in collaboration with the lab of charles
lee we are creating new experimental
individual models of glamour
basically canine pdx models
we've started on essentiality screens to
identify
k-n-glioma drivers with human relevance
and finally and i cut myself short here
and we continue to perform molecular
profiling in particular using long-range
sequencing
but to better understand the genomics of
canines canine tumors
finally i want to recognize the
collaborators and of course my lab
and in particular samira meanwhile at
this study thank you so much for
listening
and i'm happy to take questions in the q
a session later
thank you thank you a terrific
picture again of diving deeply into
understanding the
elements and how the cross comparison
to pediatric cancers is so profound
we're fortunate in this last
presentation within this section
to have andrea weber dr webber received
her phd in molecular biology from
princeton went on to a postdoctoral
fellowship at the university of
pennsylvania
and then joined uh merck and company or
she serves as both a senior
principal scientist at merck as well as
co-leading merck's
program in the clinical biomarkers area
through their translational oncology
department she provides an
important link and what we're talking
about today and what we hope to execute
tomorrow
which is to really bring translational
science into product development
for a variety of diseases and disorders
so she'll be presenting to us now if you
could please
rule that video
hello everyone my name is andy weber and
i'm from the clinical biomarkers group
in translational oncology at merck
today after a short introduction i'll be
speaking to biomarkers in the context of
pembrolizumab
monotherapy pembrolizumab is our
anti-pd1
immunotherapy agent then i'll speak to
these same biomarkers in the context of
pembrolizumab combinations
and finally i'll close by addressing the
value of biomarkers to clinical
development
first let's start with our mission as
translational scientists
our primary objective in translational
oncology is to use the findings from our
own
internal and translational
collaborations to effectively
and efficiently inform drug development
this includes reverse translation
back to our discovery oncology
organization and forward translation
to later stage clinical trials
as a translational organization we
support scientists
across the continuum of drug discovery
from discovery
through to early and late development
our biomarker focus is somewhat
different depending on the stage
of drug discovery biomarker focus in the
early stages
is to examine mechanism of action
confirm
target engagement look at
pharmacodynamic effects of new agents in
early
in discovery and early oncology in
contrast
our biomarker focus in late development
is reverse translation
and if our research has shown that
patient selection is required
we focus on diagnostic development
immunotherapy has challenged our
understanding of biomarkers particularly
when compared
to the use of biomarkers in targeted
therapy
in targeted therapy a biomarker assesses
the presence or the absence
of a specific mutation that is required
for a response
examples with which you may be familiar
include
egfr and k-ras mutations
in contrast in immunotherapy biomarkers
are assayed along a gradient which
speaks to the likelihood
that a patient may or may not respond
to an immunotherapy agent we also need
to keep in mind the prevalence of our
biomarker
and if diagnostic development is
involved we need to determine
where to draw our cut points that is
where do we establish cut points that
were that will categorize
each patient as biomarker positive or
negative
or biomarker high versus low
let's focus now on biomarkers for
pembrolizumab monotherapy
and we'll start with the expression of
pdl-1 the ligand
or pd1 its expression is measured
through immunohistochemistry
many of you may be familiar with the
results from keynote one
keynote one was the clinical trial that
established a
expression cutoff of tps
or tumor proportion score greater than
or equal to
50 for the use of pembrolizumab in
non-small cell lung cancer
in that study tps scores of greater than
or equal to 50 percent
were associated with enhanced clinical
response to pembrolizumab
data from keynote 1 led to the approval
of the first
ever companion diagnostic in
immunotherapy
for the use of pembrolizumab or ketruta
in non-small cell lung cancer
i've shown here results from keynote 42
which recently extended the use of
pembrolizumab
in the first line lung setting to
subjects with pdl1
greater than or equal to tps one percent
keynote 42 had as a primary objective
overall survival of pembrolizumab
versus platinum-based chemotherapy at
three different cut points tps 50
greater than or equal to 50 percent
greater than or equal to 20 percent
and greater than or equal to one percent
i've shown here the overall survival
curves for two of the cut points
tps fifty percent and tps one percent
the data from keynote 42 met the primary
endpoints at all three cut points
here you'll see hazard ratios of 0.69
and 0.81
for 50 and 1 respectively
indications beyond non-small cell lung
cancer
also have pdl-1 expression cut-offs
associated with their use
in in that specific tumor type and those
examples are shown in this table
let's switch gears now and talk about
gene expression
as assayed by rna-seq the next few
slides that i'll share
will speak to gene expression signatures
that have been associated with response
or resistance to pembrolizumab
merck has previously defined an
interferon gamma based
18 gene signature that we also call the
gep
it was shown to be associated with
clinical response to pembrolizumab
across multiple tumor types
using data sets external to our pembro
program
namely from the moffitt and tcga
databases
we've defined a canonical set of
signatures that represent
key biological axes involved in response
and resistance
interestingly the correlation patterns
between the various signatures
are quite similar in both the internal
pembrolizumab
data patient database and the external
data sets the study i'll tell you about
today
explored the relationships of the
various signatures shown on this slide
including the t-cell inflamed gep with
objective response rate to pembrolizumab
we used rna-seq data from baseline
patient
biopsies from several pembrolizumab
studies
the results are shown on this slide on
the left you'll see the aurocs
and the one-sided p-values associated
with each of the signatures
as we looked at the association with
response to pembrolizumab
two important things to note first the
t-cell inflamed
gep demonstrated the strongest
association
with orr to pembrolizumab
next three other rna signatures the
angiogenesis signature
angiogenesis excuse me signature the
monocyte
mdsc and a stroma emt
tgf beta signature each exhibited
statistically significant
negative associations with response to
pembrolizumab
on the right you'll see the aurocs
associated with
each of the signatures in each of the
tumor types that were included
in the analysis the size of the symbol
in this figure reflects the number of
subjects with each specific
type of cancer
here we show results from keynote 52
which is a specific
example of using the stromal tgf beta
ent
signature keynote 52
is a phase 2 pembro monotherapy
study and says flatten ineligible
patients that have not been previously
treated with systemic chemotherapy
here we had rna-seq data from 187
subjects and we observed that a lower
stromal tgf-beta emt score was
associated with favorable
bor regardless of gep status
similar to our observations with bor
longer estimated progression-free
survival times were also observed for
patients with
low versus high stromal tgf beta
emt signature scores
the bottom line here is that other
pathways
in addition to interferon gamma-based
t-cell inflammation is involved in the
response to pembrolizumab now let's talk
about tumor mutational burden
tumor mutational burden uh was shown in
a paper in science in 2018 to be
positively associated with clinical
benefit
across multiple patient cohorts treated
with pembrolizumab
in that study we showed that the
predictive utility of tmb
was independent of the gep that is in
multivariate models
tmb and gep each retained predictive
value
now let's fast forward to june of this
year
in june the fda granted tumor agnostic
approval for tmb that is pembrolizmab
is now approved for patients with
previously treated
unrespect unresectable or metastatic
cancer
with tumors that have been identified as
tnb
high using the foundation one cdx
assay from foundation medicine that
approval was based on data from keynote
158
and is supported by more recent data
shown at the right that were presented
at aacr
earlier this year in this study the tmb
was assessed by whole exome sequencing
in greater than
1700 subjects across 24
tumor types tumor mutational burden of
greater than or equal to 175 mutations
per exome was associated with enrichment
of response to pembrolizumab in these
patients with previously treated tumors
a cutoff of 175 mutations per exome
is equivalent to the 10 mutations per
megabase cut off using the foundation 1
cdx assay
now i'm going to use the my remaining
time to talk to you about some lung
studies that were published in 2019
and provided us the opportunity to study
the utility of
tmb in pembrolizumab monotherapy
versus combination studies i'll speak to
keynotes
10 and 42 which were phase
3 studies of pembrolizumab versus
chemotherapy
in a pdl1 selected population
and i'll also speak to three phase three
combination studies keynotes 21
189 and 407
this slide shows the results from
keynote 10 which is one of the
monotherapy studies
on the left you'll see the p-value for
each of the clinical endpoints
as we looked for an association with
pembrolizumab
or chemotherapy and on the right you
will see the roc
curves for o of orr for
tnv tumor tmb was associated with
outcomes for pembrolizumab as a
continuous variable
but were not associated with outcomes
for p
for chemotherapy due to time constraints
i won't show you the data but i will
point out that similar data were
observed for mono
for the monotherapy study keynote 42.
this slide shows that tmb at a cutoff
of 175 mutations per exome associates
with
overall survival in the monotherapy
study keynote 10.
you'll see that in patients whose tumors
have tmb greater than 175 mutations per
exome
we get a separation of the survival
curves for pembrolizumab
versus chemotherapy on the right however
you'll see that patients whose tumors
have tmb
less than 175 now show overlapping
survival curves
for both treatment regimens
again similar data were observed for
monotherapy
study keynote 42.
so what can we conclude about the use of
tmb in the context of pembrolizumab
monotherapy
studies we've observed that higher tnb
levels as assessed by whole exome
sequencing
were associated with improved clinical
outcomes for pembrolizumab monotherapy
in patients with pdl-1 selected
non-small cell lung cancer
in general higher tumor tnb levels were
not
associated with response to chemotherapy
there are some limitations here in that
these were exploratory retrospective
analyses
and the analysis was performed on only a
subset of patients
who had evaluable tnb data
the results here suggest that tumor tmb
may provide
additional information regarding the
clinical benefit
of pembroke monotherapy in pdl-1
selected
non-small-cell lung cancer
important to note that there was no
correlation observed between tumor tmb
and pdl1
now let's switch to these same
biomarkers in the context of
pembrolizumab combinations
so let's start with tmb
here you'll see the p-values for each of
the clinical endpoints
um as we looked for association with
response to pembro plus
chemo or chemo alone
here the results are shown for keynotes
21
189 and 407 which are all combination
studies
you'll see from the p-values that in
contrast to the monotherapy situation we
see
no association between tumor tnb and
efficacy
to pembrolizumab plus chemotherapy or
chemotherapy plus placebo
in any of the studies
here when we look at the overall
survival curves you'll see that elevated
tmb
does not correlate with overall survival
in keynote 189
in this combination study you see a
similar separation of survival curves
on the left in patients with tmb greater
than or equal to 175
and on the right in
patients whose tumors have tnb less than
175.
similar data were observed for the
combination study
keynote 407
so here in the context of combination
therapy
our conclusions are rewritten now we see
no significant association between
tumor tnb assessed by whole exome
sequencing
and the efficacy of pembrolizumab plus
chemotherapy or for platinum based
chemotherapy
alone pembrolizumab plus chemotherapy
showed an os benefit versus placebo
plus chemotherapy in both the tnb
high and tmb low subgroups
the same limitations do apply here and
that this is an exploratory
analysis and here we had tumor
tmb evaluable data in only 50
of the study participants the data
suggests however that in
comparison to tumor tmb in the
monotherapy setting
here in the combination setting we see
limited clinical utility
in the setting of first line pembro plus
chemotherapy
there are examples in which pdl1 appears
to have
limited clinical utility again in
contrast to some monotherapy
situations here i've shown the interim
analysis
of a phase two pembrolismab plus
levatinib study in
endometrial cancer these results were
published last year in lancet oncology
here the data show that the response
appears to be
independent of pdl1 status
we find that 38.5 of pdl1
positive tumors and 54.5
of pdl1 negative tumors have had a
response to the pembrolizumab
plus levatinib treatment again
showing independence of pdl1 status
now what are the value what is the value
of biomarkers to clinical development
i hope that i have convinced you that
exploratory biomarkers can facilitate a
strategic
advantage for clinical development we
can use
biomarkers to elucidate pathways
associated with response and resistance
we can discover new targets and identify
possible new combinations
and we can accelerate clinical
by success on such things such as
mechanism
of action and the recommended phase ii
dose
for novel agents biomarkers are
critical of course to things like
patient selection
and they may potentially contribute to
registrational endpoints
and as i thought about some of the
challenges
um that that we have in immunotherapy
i think it's important to understand
how biomarkers will translate to the
periphery
and how we as translational scientists
can try to maximize
biomarkers in liquid biopsies
particularly for those tumor types and
for those patients
for whom tissue is particularly limiting
and then finally how can we maximize the
use of biomarkers whether they be
predictive
prognostic or safety related in a world
of increasingly personalized medicine
so thank you for your attention and i'll
take any questions later in the q
at this a uh we're
beginning to assemble uh the
series of presenters from this morning
uh and we'll begin to open the dialogue
that for questions that were already
submitted
and we certainly encourage those we have
about 15 minutes for our q a that has
been granted by the
organizers and what i'll
attempt to do is to take some of the
questions and perhaps move those
over to one of the individuals
if they're focused on i'd say for those
presenters that are
going to be answering questions if you
could keep your
uh yourself muted i hear someone typing
for example uh
and just to know we had anticipated and
hope
we would have everyone on
the screen and it's possible that
uh the that you can
see that by being part of the video
bridge
um something i'm not uh
so in your upper left-hand side i guess
on the video bridge is where you can end
up seeing
uh the very presenters that are speaking
today
so with uh what i'd like to do is
just begin the dialogue and with a
question that came in
early that i think is important and
perhaps dr leblanc could help us with
it says the samples and data sets
generated in these canine clinical
trials become publicly available
can they be requisitioned can you give
us a little bit of a sense of how
particularly at least at cotc this is
being made available to the community
yeah so i think there are some
opportunities to share what we've
collected
we are still in the process of curating
um and doing qa
on the primary tumor samples that were
collected
from our investigators and um
and moving through that process we'll
know sort of what is
available and what's reasonable to
release and what
is of insufficient quality we also
will be releasing shortly the standard
of care osteosarcoma
data from over 100 dogs that were
treated
prescriptively with amputation and four
cycles of chemotherapy carboplatin
with very detailed demographic
information and outcome
information though that data set will be
released to the cotc participants in
that trial
and they can use it and share it at will
so there will be one
you know refined set of data released to
the community and will also be uploaded
to the integrated canine data commons
so feel free to reach out to me
specifically for any um
pointed requests for tissue or samples
and
we'll work through the appropriate
channels to try to address those
requests okay perfect
the i think what we'll do is
we'll turn to a couple of very uh
specific questions for individual
presenters and then we'll return back to
sort of a global
dialogue on particularly what the
limitations might be
to be able to
maximize yields from these canine
oncology studies for human benefit that
that this august group can can opine on
but if we move over uh quickly to
the uh area of pediatric
gliomas the uh one of the questions that
came in
i know you presented this uh
dr verhack but that's to
i think question how strongly you sense
that the pediatric human
gliomas uh are indeed more similar to
the canine
gliomas i know you presented that maybe
you could just give us a brief
sense of your sense of how
uh how strong that interpretation is
uh as one of the questions yeah sure
so thank you for that question so the we
have three lines of evidence uh
somewhat uh interdependent but still
three lines of evidence to conclude that
canine clinomas mostly
most look like pediatric gliomas which
is one
mutation burden comparable between more
similar to
pediatric tumors than to adults too it's
a high level of aneuploidy so
adult leomas do have aneuploidy but
certainly not to the higher levels
of canines and also pediatric rhythms
tend to have higher levels of
aneuploidy compared to adults three
methylation classifier which in the
brain tumor field
is a big up-and-coming way to group
um brain tumors also clinically and
we converted the the the most often used
signatures
uh to be uh working for canine tumors
and
a majority they uh these uh among 40
tumors i think 37 classified as
pediatric loyola
so to me that's pretty convincing having
said that there are still clear
differences too in particular the
absence of mutations in h3 f3a which are
very common in pediatric biomass
we didn't see any of those among among
the canines
nor did we find b ref alterations again
frequently found in pediatric tumors so
you know they're more similar but
they're not identical
great um well let's switch over and i
know we'll probably spend a reasonable
amount of time
on some of the aspects associated with
the immune checkpoint inhibitors that
we've talked two or three times and
mentioned and you'll hear more about it
coming up that
the integrated canine data commons and
the
physician veterinary physician that
leads that deborah knapp had a question
for dr
webber on whether the initial evidence
for a lower tmb
and some of the canine cancers
what do we know of that in regards to
values for canine checkpoint inhibitor
studies can you can you give us some
sense of
uh your knowledge in that space dr
webber
yeah i agree that you know at first
glance it looks like
tmv may not have you know the utility
that we
that we see in adult humans in our
clinical trials
i think that what that suggests to us is
we need to
you know be more inclusive and look you
know look for additional biomarkers that
might
actually translate from canine to the
dog
i mean sorry from canine to humid
do you is it at all likely that at least
you were using exome data in the
canine side from your knowledge of the
data and and do you think
part of that could be that you're you're
not sampling enough
information if it's just a small panel
and yeah that would have to be answered
by someone who did the canine studies
okay uh there's a
another question uh dr weber for you can
you comment on studies and results that
you've accumulated with katruda and
adoptive cell therapies
i am not able to comment on that story
okay and uh
[Music]
jeff this is will um can you hear me
okay
yeah yeah so uh to to explore the tnb
question further on the canine side from
some of the group who
have done some of the work profiling
mutation burden you know again it seems
like
from the tumor types that have been
evaluated so far
um in the dog low tmb it seems to be
pretty universal i mean we think about
the high tmb tumor types in human
lung cancer melanoma
syndrome mismatch repair we don't have
those same mutational etiologies in the
dog we don't have
cigarette smoke and lung cancer we don't
have most melanoma
the malignant versions are oral and sun
shielded
we don't have a record which syndrome in
dogs so we we tend to see lower tmb
pan cancer analysis suggests there may
be a small population of higher tmb
tumors that are associated with
broadly it's it's we're all recognizing
that
much of naturally occurring canine
cancer is low tmb
and yet i i would argue that and and i'm
sure others as well that
this is actually a rich area for us to
better
understand uh what we can do in the
setting of low tmb
and even to speak to dr webber your
presentation um
and the results from the keynote studies
and
and frontline use of pembro versus
pembroke it's platinum
where presumably platinum's playing some
role in even inducing dna damage
and may have a role in association with
that response
and why tnb may be less of a useful
biomarker in that setting
i think there's really a lot of key work
that we can do in
many of these canine cancers both to
advance
combination therapy in the dog but also
ask a lot of those
pressing questions that are emerging in
human oncology around
other correlates of response to a
checkpoint blockade
right dr gardner any thoughts or
comments more broadly on the
results from canine around
the immune profiling that's done
from your standpoint that would be of
good general
interest to this group
um you know i don't know if i have any
additional
data to share necessarily on the immune
profiling standpoint but what i can say
is that there are
increasing efforts concerted efforts
from multiple groups
to to really try and
move that forward and and make it
something that
is is out there and a bit more useful on
the canine side
okay well
sort of a combined question i might pose
between dr
leblanc and dr webber and it's just
an idea this conference of course is
cross-correlating
pediatric uh human
trials of course with the relevance to
many of the canine
samples and there's been this remarkable
work of nancy goodman
who's the remarkable patient advocate
and founder of kids versus cancer who
was able to get the
creating hope act not just
funded through congress but actually
re-refunded
or re-authorized or whatever the right
word was
and of course that act creates
market-based incentive for pharma
companies to spur
pediatric cancer development
again a lot of us see this value in the
canine model system as directly
supporting
that i wonder whether either of you have
any thoughts on
whether pharma's a potential
opportunity to benefit from something
like this could
somehow give a halo effect to the to the
dog
um i mean i i don't know that i can
comment on our our open industry trials
right now but i will say that you know
when we work with first-in-class agents
um that are in the pre-ind setting if we
can relate the
findings from the tumor types that we
study in dogs to a relevant pediatric
population
that becomes incredibly valuable um in
the process of the regulatory filings
and things that are
um you know that pharma is responsible
for so i i can
see that value um but it's not that we
can widely discuss it at this point i
hope that will change the next couple
years but
we're actively working in that space
and i think it's important for us in
industry to understand
um the gaps that the canine model will
fill compared to
you know some of the mouse models that
have been you know traditionally used
and who
that that do not show translatability
into the human so i think
over the next few years hopefully you
know
drilling down on what aspects you know
the dog can inform on particularly like
you said for those new agents
you know as they move into pediatric
studies
well the the next question then as we we
have
a few minutes left is is really to ask
for
general open discussion from those
that are on the panel to
really ask that that question can you
comment on
whether there's you know those those
barriers that really are
uh holding back our ability to
the obstacles for introducing canine
comparative trials to inform
novel drug development and and perhaps
dr verhack based on your
uh both your your work and uh where
you're
currently located is there a thought
that you'd particularly want to share
and then i hope it's open for others to
describe as well
uh i guess
being more on the basic science side and
the characterization side not having
been closely involved
with uh clinical trials of canines
my my thought would be that
a more of a dialogue between those areas
would be would be useful
in order so that the trials are
appropriately designed
you know the problem will be interpreted
and maybe let me just leave it at that
just to have others comment
and anyone else
i can go ahead and jump in on that um
you know i really just
echo what was just that i think one of
the things that becomes really important
is you know knowing what the question
you're trying to answer is
and trying to design a study in a way
that
really gets at that and so that
involves you know a team essentially um
and that team you know should involve
individuals on on all sides of the
equation
yeah so others with questions on current
bottlenecks
to maximize the yield from these canine
oncology studies for human benefit
dr hendrix you seem ready to say
something
yeah um so i'll echo what both heather
and
role said and just to add that you know
building um
correlative biomarker studies either
designing trials with those
prospectively in mind uh around which
there's certainly challenges or
um you know building in robust
retrospective studies like what dr
leblanc described in terms of the
osteosarcoma data and the deep
comprehensive work that's being done
there with um
with you know really a lot of outcomes
information those sorts of studies are
going to
increasingly be key we've done some of
the early key work to map genome
landscapes now we need to look at
some of the clinical correlates so
marrying those two types of study
together
is really critical well let me thank
everyone again that was a presenter let
me also thank again
rika for the remarkable ability she's
been able to pull this together
again we're grateful and we're right at
the
end of our session time and so again we
thank the sponsors
we thank again all the presenters and we
look forward to the rest of the meeting
so thank you very much